er fällt tief florian burkhards alias
elektroboiler liefert sich selbst in die
psychiatrische klinik ein
diagnose angststörung bei narzisstischer
persönlichkeitsstruktur florians welt
ist plötzlich eng und klein
wo sie doch vorher nicht groß genug sein
konnte für sein riesiges ego
mit 21 wollte der primarlehrer filmstar
werden und hatte einen dreisten plan
fotografen engagiert findet oder als es
mit der schauspielerei in hollywood
nicht so recht klappen will notierte
exzentrische bo flugs eine neue karriere
dann kommt der überdruss und der bruch
er verliebt sich in einen bauernsohn
schmeiß alles hin sucht das glück im
privaten
doch sein lava läuft ihm davon
diesen gebrochenen selbstdarsteller
begegnet dokumentarfilmer marcel gisler
mit viel empathie und
fingerspitzengefühl
der wunsch nach einem wert um das große
raum groß jahr nach einig als fehler
macht
florian als extremes kind seiner zeit
das unermüdlich um öffentliche
anerkennung und er wird internet-pionier
webdesigner und als elektro boy
gefeierter könig der zürcher partyszene
absolut irre heitz überflutet er geht
ans limit opfer wird er selbst es folgte
der zusammenbruch
die angststörung als er aus der
psychiatrie entlassen wird lebt er mit
hund hugo in einer kahlen wohnung die er
kaum zu verlassen war so krass nach
einer für biel auf die skiflug sie was
das wallis die welteroberung das ist ein
fluss oder situation und er sich nur der
könne persönlich wirklich ein fall der
seite mit ich habe es eine 2 erfahren
können sammler und erschloss zurück und
hat jede erfahrung machen und mit der
welt und man kann das alles zurücklassen
vergangenheit und ich glaube die brüche
psychischen absturz gekommen
ganz einfach
ist eine tatsache dass man nach handelt
der film entwickelt sich zu einem
familiendrama
die krankheit zwingt florian sich seiner
herkunft aus beengten katholischen
verhältnissen zu stellen und sich mit
seinen eltern auseinander zu setzen
musik elektro blickt hinter die mauer
des schweigens ein tragisches ereignis
aus der vergangenheit kommt dabei zum
vorschein
eindrücklich nie voyeuristisch schafft
es regisseur marcel gisler an familien
tabus zu rütteln
als pflicht für griechischer mit dem
bild wurde wie das interview jetzt
empfehlen mal sechs fahrern akte waren
alle tapeten sind aber kresse und
präsentiert sich relativ nackt jetzt das
ende von elektro bau ist überraschend
und berührend wie der ganze film
das leben des heute 40 jährigen florian
nimmt nochmals eine wende